germany's leopard 2 main battle tank is
an export hit for german industry
the vehicle can be used in both urban
environments and in open terrain
as demonstrated by the bundesphere at a
recent training event
gulf states have been especially
interested in buying the german tank
export permits are way up in the first
half of this year
especially to qatar german opposition
parties are
up on arms
in all of these countries women have
minimal rights there are dictatorships
as well they're even worse
saudi arabia is worse than qatar but i
would say in this kind of region in
crisis where the arab spring has been
bloodily suppressed
no weapon should be delivered it's
unacceptable
the economics minister defended the
increase in german military export
permits
a secret government commission only
grants approval after the issues are
carefully considered
there is not just one golf state very
clear differentiations are made
and if we take the example of the arab
world in egypt
we have very clearly decided based on
the current very unclear political
situation to put
everything on hold
but there is a significant increase in
german military exports to many gulf
states
berlin sees the emirates as important
partners in the fight against terrorism